You may have previously learned the
order of operations using the mnemonic
PEMDAS.
P stands for parentheses, E stands for
exponents, M stands for multiply,
D stands for divide, A stands for
add, and S stands for subtract.
If PEMDAS is a helpful way for
you to remember the order of operations,
that's great.
But keep in mind that even
though M comes before D PEMDAS,
you should still also do multiplication
and division at the same time.
Likewise, even though A comes before S,
you should add and
subtract at the same time.
For multiplying and
dividing as well as for adding and
subtracting, always work
from left to right.
Now that we know the order of
operations, let's try a problem.
operations, let's try problem.
Let's start with 20/5 x4+6 squared.
Enter your answer in the box.